it's just you
she
are you scaring them again what did I
tell you about that you cut that out
they deserve better they're good people
leave them alone
welcome to siren head retribution do you
know that a character is starting to
pick up steam when it gets names like
siren head retribution because
everyone's trying to make a siren ed
game well let's see what this one's
about all right whoa
all right I should check with Dan and
Riley in the station to see what needs
maintenance yeah some tells me that um
this looks pretty good you know
something tells me that Dan and Riley
aren't gonna be there something tells me
they're gonna be very dead where is
everybody was the power off reasons.i
Dan should be allowed to eat pasta in
the ranger cheap generator Greg Mottola
I like pasta it's convenient you can eat
pizza all the time basically it's the
same food I like pasta it's very funny
very funny
hi Daniel Carter of sound mind and body
do solemnly declare that I have died of
boredom we barely even get calls on the
radio anymore
even my Walkman broke just this morning
it's 1988 what does a man have to do for
some excitement around here Riley if you
see this know that I died in Restless
agony and will forever haunt you unless
the next time you go into Atlanta you
bring a Nintendo Entertainment System
back with you that is I'm begging you
your deceased friend Dan kind of like
this one day Dan you will live here
sincerely you in Chicago Chicago Oh
Chicago baby the ultimate place to go I
like this word building
Chattahoochee National Forest ranger
station my name is Riley how can I help
hey I'm I think I'm being followed by
someone what's your location sir who's
following you I haven't seen them I just
hear some strange things out in the
woods and some heavy footsteps sir I
need your location if I'm gonna help you
I think I'm on the yellow trail this guy
better back off do not confront
whoever's following you sir my partner
is on the way right now can you tell me
what they look like no it's I mean I
haven't seen him yet I can hear him
though
okay sir calm down what does he look
like big really big sounds like he has a
damn radio with him to radio like a
tornado siren or something yours is
probably running to be honest I'm
probably getting freaked out over
nothing actually our tornado siren has
been broken for days radio static
neither party spoke hang on I think I
think I can see wait oh my god hello sir
can you hear me interesting I got an
idea what's up dad that person's death
is next still come on we got places to
be since today is Thanksgiving at all
why don't we just forget rose and get a
bite to eat
people might still be out there
you remember last year with the missing
kids if over you would you've wanted
people to stop patrolling here we go
what's that supposed to mean you know
that there was nothing that you could do
to find those kids right I know that one
of them was your sister but you're on
some thin ice now Dan point is you're
torturing yourself come on back okay I
made dinner but not did you hear that
feedback maybe listen thanks for making
dinner I'll be back in a minute but I
need to go check out something real
quick well that doesn't sound good okay
Riley I've gone for help my project cars
in the garage out back it still needs a
few parts before it can run but I know
that you can piece it together Vendetta
or not take my car and go now wish me
luck
damn I need to start the generator
before turning on the main power uh what
about all the problems that are
happening should be around garage if I
miss you Riley mom oh man lots of notes
it's cool it makes it feel lived in whoa
box box tiny box Tim it's you that other
box is oblong it's a rectangle it's you
tiny box Tim Wow you're a rectangle do
that's okay
your twin brother back there doesn't
matter tiny hey you been spent so long
it's good to see you why don't you come
with me let me come with me a little
buddy oh let me drop your friggin at
least a foot that's six feet thank you
days since anything happened at all ever
well tiny box Tim looks like there's a
mystery but we gotta get it solved oh hi
all right well this seems normal
- do you replace head taillights grease
components finished clean partial
reattach we'll get a new battery filled
with gas roots it's a wheel battery and
gas that's what I need to get this going
have you seen that a burner oil grease
no it's like a blown fuse bought from
big bill hell's cars for a steal
they said Leigh found rat in the trunk
got started without a muffler it made my
ears ring befriended rat in the truck
named Walter well that's adorable
okay so fuse so where's a fuse damn
where's fuse never seen a fuse oh all
right okay all right Tim I guess we got
to go Riley did you take the ladder back
to your shed again I know that you need
it because you're short
the other one is all the way in the
water tanks give me a break will ya I
don't find that joke very funny find it
funny at all right let's go find
something I'm here to do maintenance not
wander off in the woods I thought I need
to go find a fuse or a ladder what do i
do what do I need wait what did I need
wait I forgotten what I need what do I
need I missed it lick see and put it on
screen again for everyone to mock me
good excellent thank you
two hours later all right I'm back I had
to restart the game to get this one
prompt so I can know what to do
yep looks like a blown fuse thankfully I
have some extra in the back of it
alright fine what if I got rusty when
looking at an outlined object to grab it
I know all right Tim you wait here at
the van keep it safe ah be back I'll be
back I'll be back for you alright
slammer Brammer boink easy
that's dude like a dream like dream now
I can turn on the main power in this
station well now without Tim Tim you see
anything weird out in these woods good
excellent that's what I like to hear
yeah the clunk
all right I was looking away
I was looking away what happened oh I
might just eternally bone to always miss
it because I turn away at the low whoa
oh my god my van my van maybe I can get
that car in the garage running Tim good
thing I didn't leave you by the van that
would have been a tragic demise all
right well Oh the siren is gone
that was siren it and I missed it great
what is that oh it's my run bar okay so
I need wheel battery and gas you gotta
go find it all right Tim I'm gonna have
to leave you behind here you stay watch
this car I'll bring you the material you
get it all set up okay you got it all
right my cottage damn your voice sounds
different it's almost like you haven't
spoken in five years what happened look
out there's monsters in the woods thanks
Tim thank you stamina does not reach oh
it's one of those humans that doesn't
ever catch their breath I get it I
understand all right so what am i
approaching a cabin sure
well that doesn't sound very good hello
a wheel Dan didn't you need gas for that
car of yours either way I bought some
and left some in the utility shed
where's the utility shed is there
anything else in here that I would
possibly need
maybe I'm writing this down as a
reminder or maybe as a warning but
either way I think I know how that siren
thing works you can't see you but it can
hear your shape it hears everything
that's why I uses sirens you can hear
everything it knows where you are even
if you hide if it wants you it's already
coming don't stop don't make any noise
don't let it catch you Dan I hope you're
still alive to find this Riley sounds
like you're both alive what do you mean
don't stop don't make any noise I
thought that's didn't ain't that the
thing that the things that the thing
[Music]
what what stay moving stay quiet stay
alive keep dogs on a leash both good
good info my steps are real loud hey
stop stop I don't know what it means by
stay moving stay quiet how do I stay
quiet if I stay moving
damn get fired up why did the wheel up
come back with the whale shut up don't
be rude oh sorry I didn't mean it like
that
oh hey Oh
oh no no no no
Tim everything all right here I'll
stitch it in
all right thanks Tim your voice is
getting better I think thank you
throat lozenger all right um I don't
know how to be quiet keep dogs on leash
great is this the utility shed I see gas
and I thought it was a French horn okay
Dan if you know some I find this note
just know that I'm on my way back to the
station something attacked my car listen
for the sirens stay away okay I don't
know I don't know what to do no no no oh
that's terrifying oh I hate it oh I hate
that
okay hear him I've got a bit of a
problem Tim Tim I've got a bit of a
problem
Tim please tell me that's you connecting
to the internet Tim please
we got big problems Tim all right the
big problem in particular is that I
don't know where the last thing is gonna
be
he was gas was a gas that battery
battery I don't know where a battery
would be Tim I don't know if we're gonna
get out of this one oh I believe in you
God man
Tim your voice it's real bad I guess the
only thing I can do is try to go for
these southern ones and hope it seems to
be over that way so I'm gonna go this
way you know maybe I should just stop
looking well that's not good
[Music]
did you say what say he turned himself
into a pickle is the funniest I've
ever seen
that's hilarious and horrifying please
leave me alone
this isn't something that I can use to
retire I don't know what the hell that
was
I got a ladder you step back mister man
I got a ladder
Oh what is happening it could be right
next to me and I would never know
you can't you can't you can't you can't
you couldn't you could never had two
ladders says will you get HPR is suck my
ass dan I'm sorry I won't be able to
making it back to the station after all
it's here after all this time it's here
I don't know why maybe it knows that I
was researching it somehow but I won't
let this opportunity pass me by not now
not ever
I'm coming for you now you siren headed
son of a I want my sister back
oh well Russian experiment demon alien
sound of terror radioactive echolocation
yeah pretty sure all these things
correct all correct yes all correct all
of them every one of them I am stuck Wow
what is it dear
dear bear people dear bear people well
that's you know it's really unfortunate
that you're over there mister man
because that's the direction that I want
to go can I get a gun the other game
gave me a gun I'm going for mistake
mistake I won't need to be that I'm
pretty sure everything I need won't be
this far oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no no no no there's
nothing here oh no it was supposed to be
another thing oh that's not a please
alright so I'm gonna check that up there
oh yeah oh wow right in front of me
right right in okay you know that's a
little rude that's not cool that's not
cool that's not cool
why would you do that that's so not cool
that's so not cool
[Music]
that is very not cool ouuuu yeah I can
do that too there's nothing out here it
was supposed to be here and it's not
why does stamina not regenerate oh it's
not here it was supposed to be here and
it is not Oh No
Brij oh hi Oh No oh hey Macarena I don't
know man there was supposed to be
something on this trail but I didn't see
it I did kind of go off the trail though
so let me try again
am i slower than I was why do I feel
like I'm slow even slower what how what
please please don't kill me I have a
ladder you want a ladder buddy
I died with my ladder all right cool
well I didn't get to the end of that one
that's okay not bad that was pretty good
it's bit odd but not bad it was good it
definitely like had the panic there it's
good I like running being a limited
resource you can't do it forever it's a
bit of a change from just the short
burst to being like your legs only work
this much and if you go over a god help
you
I like that that's not bad anyway at
least Tim lived all right
this is smudged hold forward to move
space to scream I think I just used up
all my screaming oh oh nope I got scream
back okay T why is it what's going on
with it
wait alright I was a little confused
because there was this like gray box
over my vision that seemed to be too
small for this screen but what the
hacking help what in the fresh help okay
I don't know I don't know what that is I
don't know why that is what am I looking
for I was looking for the letters I
found one now I've lost him oh this is
found the e-everybody oh I can run oh my
running and my screaming is tied
together oh and and and enter Enderman
int 10 Oh
I was there I don't like it h/h there
then her green friend
bean Wow no thank you Jesus scream you
silent piece of garbage oh no oh no hey
you take my screen no no I got but I got
bean that's not bad okay the letters
seem to be in a static place so that's
good and the maze doesn't seem to be too
big scared me I scrubbed and Dee Dee Doo
Dah scrubbed indeed oh that's a new one
okay it's gonna avoid it
alright cool can't avoid it
oh no there's more in them more in the
ass back of the hole what am I looking
at what am I looking at the D Oh
interesting
hey that's what it was fiend it was seen
I didn't get the question mark but
that's not bad hey that wasn't bad that
wasn't so bad that was pretty good I
liked that a lot
how does some charm do it I like the
charm hand drawn charm I like that
that's good
this is goodbye Gordon I'm a big fan of
half-life been playing it since I was
young and playing it since the first one
played opposing force played blue shift
played a lot of mods about it played
scientist slaughterhouse paid a lot of
cool things I don't know if I've ever
played a half-life horror game half-life
does have some horror elements to it but
this one is specifically a horror fan in
goodbye Gordon now Gordon we better get
a move on this is a faithful recreation
this is a very faithful recruit this is
a faithful recreation of the original
half-life oh my oh my oh my oh my oh my
do they rip the models or that level Oh
No hey buddy um Barney doctor require
play holiness what oh I still have a
flashlight Oh play coins play coins play
once Quinn's play
what are you over there
what I see you coming down yeah what are
you doing what are you doing what are
you doing we'll give you hi are you
gonna kill me don't come any closer I
have pepper spray in my nipples oh so
you're gonna like eat me all right well
that's unfortunate for me then all right
goodbye Gordon try it again
okay so I need to get play coins it is a
little unfortunate that the reset is so
far behind I imagine I might die again
oh well it's my fault I owe my own
stupidity led me to my demise
hmm well this was not part of it okay
call me a nerd but this was not part of
the original level design I actually
know that very specifically this intro
area I played more times than you could
possibly imagine
oh no no no no yeah I know this area
very I will not be swayed by such cheap
jump scares you will not get me in such
a manner
Oh trap me in there you can't do it you
remember what you remember how much of a
douche you are you remember how badly
you're gonna suck compared to me where's
the g-man
g-man oh well oh um uh uh well is it
dead-ends okay that's weird
all right sure whatever you say man dude
get away from me I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to get the fifth and six
ones without running away oh this is two
different directions I should have gone
a different route Oh No okay buddy thank
you cafeteria okay I remember I
immediately I these are things that I am
very aware of can I get my HEV suit oh
oh he's quick oh no no no no no no not
like this
not your course no no no no no no no no
okay I will get you in just a second
chopper be patient all right gotta go
down you remember what I did it I beat
the video game well that just reminded
me that I have yet to play half-life
Alex even on my own I'm not gonna make a
video series about it I'm gonna enjoy
that on my own but I haven't played it
yet that's why I will I'm pretty good
not bad I like it pretty cool what they
did I don't know if they just ripped the
levels but they added some of themselves
- not bad not bad
so those three scary games hey Lucien
I'll let you close out this video if you
promise not to startle these fine folks
here you got this one hey I trust you
and don't worry you're in good hands
all right you carry on see you around
hey good job on the video well done
I hope this time because the last
go
[Music]